okay oh hey Congressman uh you polished
a shitload of this off man yeah he kept
telling me it was water congressman how
does the GOP plan to cut taxes while
increased defense spending well yeah and
we've heard that one before Reagan you
know I mean Budo economics George Bush
the first called it I the serious answer
is that although there'll be about
thirty billion dollars of additional
spending with my colleagues help of
general Matagorda now now additional
over last year's uh and everything
everything going to need more well and
now that I know what's been like more
than every other country in the world
combined that's an exaggeration but we
spend no it's not no well we could I
mean the country closest to us is China
at 215 billion a year and we spend about
seven hundred that's not even casual war
will spend about four percent of GDP a
little less than that of the NATO allies
are promising to spend 2 percent of GDP
there's no question we invest more but
the answer to your question is that
mostly what we're going to try and do is
leverage the fact that secretary mattis
is somebody who really does want to do
the reforms to wring out some of the
cost and that includes some of the
expensive toys that are being put in
instead of some basic equipment that can
be bought more effectively includes the
f30 or f-18 the super what about the
version of the tax cutting part because
I you know I I saw during the campaign
Trump was talking tough about the hedge
fund managers these guys just push push
numbers around in a computer screen
we're gonna we're gonna I haven't heard
that lately yet that well number that
night after he won the election he was a
twenty one for dinner and he was leaving
in some hedge fund guys there is like
we're going to get your taxes down so
that looks like kind of a calm to me you
know says someone thinking about
campaign and you know I you've got two
sides of the issue here right now
they're talking about a border
adjustment tax it won't work I oppose it
and a lot of my Republican colleagues
oppose it and that's a revenue increase
that's supposed to pay for a big part of
the decrease but
in fact it is not a sensible it's going
to start a trade war if we do it and so
and it will act as a tax on consumer
good it'll consumption yes if why don't
which people pay income tax
okay what is Donald Trump a income tax
well people do hate rich people I don't
mean rich like you I mean super rich
well but if only we were rich enough not
to pay bill I'm not so good he's super
rich in fact these two kind of a ritual
right over here very rich I don't want
to try to outrun anyone but do
understand I was too poor to get into
this administration in the cabinet
position you're hardly true for you the
rich guy in Congress I've remembered
that not enough to get in the cabinet
really okay
what but I know what you're saying but
rich people do pay it'll be within here
terrible all right water Fran would you
ever consider getting a smart phone or
joining the social media age no you are
you're famously not too hooked up to the
news I'd rather have a smart Congress
I can give you a list of replacements
hey he's sitting right here
ha ha ha well compare list tipping ah
arson that's what was it like to be
roast master for Donald Trump oh yeah
yeah yeah I you know my only my if I'm
completely honest my recollection of the
top of the time and this is why the
current state is so bizarre is that he
was perfectly Pleasant and in a little
boring
everybody says that that in person yeah
he's a different a little boring like
there was just think that was just run
there to do a job and right and that was
it and I entered my personal interaction
with him when I wasn't on stage making
masturbation jokes to his face what was
that what it was pretty limited roaring
his heart yeah that was house except it
was pretty limited and I would say this
is this is a business guy like like a
thousand others you know and I think
that's part of like I remember reading
something that yet and I feel like
that's part of what the administration
needs to try to translate to people that
you experience a completely different
person in the demagogue that he's become
but with it but it is it's very
important how you present yourself
now I particularly the wrestler it's so
important this is why I say like when
you say I I think we need to get him
there I don't know that he has that in
him because even jazzes whoever whoever
whoever you are whether you're Donald
Trump or Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton who ever you are if you are on a
stage for months at a time being deified
and lionized by thousands upon thousands
of people that will affect any one of us
Rand you know and I'll go too far say I
threw her moments in the debate where I
started to see Bernie play into the
crowd a little bit just a bit and and
and Bernie ahead of stronger stuff and
you not have been and if you had at when
when Roman generals returned from the
war and they had a big parade people
were cheering and throwing rose petals
there was always a slave standing behind
the general whispering in his ear all
men are mortal and the AL fame is
fleeting yet he was a slave out of once
that you
you could have somebody's not a slave
hanging you don't you understand I can
remember those parades
not everyone waves with all their
fingers yeah you get that message uh
yeah I've noticed that when I retired
but politics people waved and used all
their fingers of yesterday so in the
absence of his ability to curtail that
instinct in himself it's up to Congress
it's up to Congress I guess only I and
the courts I get you an equation about
liberals on the same way but but this
man is a malignant narcissist I mean
he's been diagnosed that way it cannot
it's not in person right you can't see
it from afar you can't as a malignant
narcissist have been someone who the
only metric with him is if he says good
things about me I like him
that's Vladimir Putin if white
supremists say nice things and they're
fans he just cannot it doesn't
additionally put them down we teach
Ellison he prays this week because keith
Ellison said he would win during the
campaign this is the only metric he has
if you say you like me you're good yeah
if you criticize me I must not that that
that cannot come out well no one race
and we are we all it's like Bush after
9/11 we all desperately wanted him to be
good because we needed him to be good
and we and we need this guy to be good
and the problem is when he gets up there
and he says they reported that there
wasn't a standing ovation and paren
there was like that doesn't [ __ ]
freak you out yes it's no good that's
like that doesn't worry you how do you
don't know where were you how does it
how does that know I will be concern you
I worry every day that as great as our
country is and as great as our people
are our leaders let them down regularly
I worry about that because the fact is
our country deserves better leadership
than we've had for a very long time it
deserves a Congress that works together
he is different it deserves it yet
you're putting him in a continuum with
people who I never liked it's billions
Bush you know what I wouldn't pay to be
president with it
but what the cure the cure is for our
current situation is as fast as possible
look at every good nomination in the
opinion of the Senate and unanimously
consent get them through get through
hundreds or thousands of confirmations
of people that are acceptable don't
stall anyone that's good look I guess
the faster we fill out the government
the faster the government is run by
people that are mutually acceptable
there's a lot of like yeah yeah I was
your husband a favor so you know it's
true it was general mal secretary Kelly
is absolutely qualified and I know
homeless is the new accurate national
security national security
how is president we're going to have any
good for anybody yeah well it's also
well respected we have was general
Dunford he's on he's a carryover but
okay bomb appointment these are objects
everybody's right but the fact is the
sooner we get we don't have a secretary
of the army the Secretary of the army
nomination pulled out you can't confirm
those that you don't have right but
those that are lined up
let's get them through as quickly as
possible because America is better it's
when some of them are terrible
I mean what's the hurry paramshanti
you'll care of most of them I've heard
of her terrible I mean all of them are
horrible well no senator just just us
nobody else the fact is if you take all
of them that you know we're going to be
confirmed that a reasonably good that
have been properly vetted and you just
look at Chuck Schumer and say look we're
going to you see all these guys let's
get them there and then by the way let's
take all the time in the world no matter
whether someone's high or low to slow
down the ones we object and that's
exactly what's happened we approved
elaine chao in about ten minutes right
and and and madis and we we did a
60-vote rule change to allow matters to
go through it took one day so if the
nominee is good it can move fast the
first can you play without a Democrat
how can this horrible cabinet on the
Democrat no no no what I'm blaming is it
are selling and by the way vented the
stalling well why do you have a Supreme
Court nomination here's you shouldn't
have
me house in Senate right Dana the fact
is though that if we take and you're
right about a couple of nominations
although I can't figure out why Chuck
Schumer suddenly decided line Chow
should be voted no on but uh it was not
a wise move but if you look at it and
you take thirty hours for each person it
will be the 25th re-election of Donald
Trump before you get one cabinet and all
the staff in there so no it's not good
okay we have an obligation we we all
have an obligation to get people in so
the government wrong I will say we
should say no to someone your eyes one
of the problems there is Merrick garland
yes yes yes what happened to him kind of
the PO unconscionable unconscious hire a
lot of people in Senate who just aren't
feeling and I know that's not your
specific department but it is your party
that was always pulling the Constitution
I carry it around in my pocket but you
don't read it because it says you get
the president by way it's on the iPhone
paper one all right in fairness though
Richard Nixon saw not one but two of his
appointments turned down until he picked
it outright leftist it is not new line
of Senate who was a leftist blackman
blackman blackman like a leftist he
wasn't a black man no but if you look at
the court unless wait a minute
interpreter the phrase in fairness
Richard Nixon
we crave in fairness to the Senate the
Senate has been dysfunctional on
appointment confirmations not to that is
in many times at the new failing Supreme
Court seat my first time yes say my one
can thank God we're not in point though
is that if we sit in the echo chamber of
just resistance resistance resistance
2018 will be lost by liberal movement
and 2020 will also if it will happen so
it's hard for what's hard for a lot of
us to wrap our brains around like you
guys come on here very articulate very
well-spoken very dignified and you
reporting to a guy who's so not that how
we don't work for that guy I really
never know I didn't say in that point I
mean if we just make a caricature of the
right and the toronto-kailasam area who
doesn't believe that was everyone when
Obama did when Obama did stupid stuff we
call him on it but if we were to call
him on it but this entire debate was no
hot water all over town literally Trump
were thirsty million people voted for
him and they had a reason and we can't
write they their diamond absolutely like
they had some legitimate some of them
are they aren't being an earldom
we're no some of them are dumb some of
them are just racist and some of our and
some of them are so turned off by the
stuff you were talking about before
that's the Democrats have been doing a
lot of them feel left out they drive
disrespect right particularly rural a
right and so Democrats are they learned
even if they're old fat and white do
what Trump does pretend you care about
them hmm I'm not all dumb or fat I think
no no but I'm just saying that if we
just caricature them as that then we
will never really understand it but the
thing of a caricature themselves is the
problem I guess it right when Sean
Spicer gets out there and just does the
bidding that it's not helped by this
constable what are we supposed to say
well always Hillary asked the election
how else how else is the same person
supposed to react when you're coming out
and saying that Green is blue I mean
Green is green and it's just like what
happens in Milo I mean you know if
you're just like f off f off s off like
not the conversation we're going to go
anywhere world is Rosa Carter and I was
a human but everybody's buddies also a
guy who like like I looked there are two
varieties people to me this guy's like
Bill O'Reilly where I really do think
believe what he says and those guys like
Milo who just wants to [ __ ] get a
rise out of people right i I think those
and in that and I disagree with O'Reilly
I'm not rising on the Sun let's listen
I'm buddies with this guy we're yeah
there's what happened guys right were
the guys say yeah you know it's you
should be allowed to speak out of it but
yeah but when it comes from the [ __ ]
White House that that's a problem yes we
got it thank you very much everybody
[Applause]